[Music]
hello
and welcome good morning good day good
evening wherever in the world you are
joining us from today
i am so thrilled that you are here my
name is will
let us know where you are tuning in from
and then three words that would describe
you
we will be making use of these three
words in a little bit so
even if you aren't to come up with ones
that fit right at this moment
we have a little bit more time to
workshop those i'll go ahead and get us
started
i want to make sure that we're able to
maximize the time we have today
so to set the map for what we're gonna
do
i have an exercise that we're gonna
start we already
started to precede it with the three
words that describe you
we'll do a little bit more with that but
with that exercise that is gonna be a
running theme that we're gonna continue
to unpack today
because my goal is to really help all of
you
better understand the holistic review
process that we use here at stanford gsb
there's a lot of kind of myth and rumor
and
it can often feel like the evaluation
process and the admissions process is a
black box
but it doesn't have to be that way so my
goal today is to help you
understand more about that process so
that today can be the foundation for
application week each of our events this
week are geared towards helping you
understand with a bit more detail
both the parts of the application as
well as tips strategies
frameworks that you can use and apply to
really help put your best foot forward
in this process
maybe you're not thinking about stanford
ultimately maybe business school doesn't
end up being for you
my hope is that also through some of the
exercises that we're able to do together
these are things
not just dependent on outcome but you're
also going to find
value in that process and these are ways
to really think about
what is it that you really want to do
what's that next step you're going to
take in your life
and how why we able to assemble the
tools skill sets
learnings um that'll help you get there
whether it's business school
hopefully it's the gsb but anywhere in
your life that those come from
how can we get from point a to point b
in a way that's right for you
so coming back to today's events a
holistic review primer just to get a
sense of
what is it what is it not because
oftentimes it's that
what is it not space where we can be the
cleanest and clearest and really help
kind of
illuminate the process from there we'll
go ahead and talk about
what it is we do look for and where we
find it
and then what does that mean for you and
i think that's where we really get into
the spirit of this week's events
how can you think about the application
pieces
and the application process in a way
that you can understand hey
maybe these are the details i should be
sharing about myself
oh i didn't know reflection kind of in
this realm was okay
or you know i just have a question about
you know transcripts or testing
we have events for that as well but the
more questions that we're able to
initiate
the more answers and the greater clarity
we're going to be able to provide
we'll have about 50 minutes together on
today's live session
for those of you who might be watching
this on replay
i'll give cues for you know let's go
ahead and pause here
and then give yourself some time to go
through this exercise
and then jump back on in to continue to
see how we unpack
process and connect the dots between the
different things we're doing
and the mba gsb application process
all right let's get going so as a
preface
there is a ton of information out there
and
i think even that is an understatement
um
there's a lot of advice some of it is
great advice
some of it you know otherwise
but take anything you hear with a grain
of salt including the things that i'm
going to be sharing
with you today and that our staff will
be sharing with you over the course of
the week
we can speak truth about the application
process and how we
interpret and evaluate um and that's our
goal
this week to really um lift that curtain
in terms of what you should do as an
individual however
part of the beauty of this process is
there is no right way or wrong way
it's really how are we able to give you
the power to understand
what is it that you want how are we
gonna get there
what are the elements of your journey
and your story
that you are going to let shine and sing
through this process
we want to give you the power and that
looks different for each and every one
of you
part of this is understanding who you
are how you show up in spaces
and as you think even beyond the mba
like experience what does that mean for
how you navigate through life
this is just one step on an ongoing
journey of your life
so take anything with a grain of salt
this is no
rule book but rather uh maybe a
orientation guide to some different
things to help you understand or
kick start that process if you ever get
stuck so
hopefully take that come in fresh eyes
on willingness to try new things and
then we'll
go down some really interesting paths
all right
so it all starts with you
um and this is not an understatement
this is going to be the theme that comes
up throughout
the week so we are actually going to
start application week
by talking about you so grab a piece of
paper
um maybe you're just jotting things down
on your in um on your tablet
maybe you open up you're opening up a
window
but i'm gonna give you a little bit of
time so
let's start off make a short list about
yourself
i say 10 things here um but definitely
feel free to do more
here are some examples of things you
might be writing about
let's start with those three words
sometimes being able to crystallize and
distill
those elements of who you are and the
things that resonate for you
can be great a great starting point to
unpack and learn more
about yourself which is what the mba is
all about as well
yes it's about building some of those
core business fundamentals the skill
sets that you're going to
need to be able to lead a group or
organization in any setting
and at stanford there's that extra piece
right that leadership development
that investment in you to help you
understand why
should someone follow you to start that
conversation
you need to begin at least hopefully
with at least some semblance or
understanding of who you are so let's go
ahead and
start that process together what are
some things you do for fun
what are things that excite you maybe
when you pick up a book
these are the types of things that keep
you turning those pages
when you see a show on tv or maybe
you're watching a movie you're like
oh let me go learn more about that and
then you go up
you do a little bit of internet
searching to learn more what are those
things
maybe it's a topic you can talk about um
at length with your friends
so anything and everything is fair game
here
i'll give you a couple more uh a little
bit more time to write through
so don't if you aren't able to make it
through all 10 no worries
as long as you get a couple of these
bullet points going for
our extended use of this list um you're
headed on the right spot
so as example i did this along with you
so my here's my cheat sheet post-it with
some of the things about myself
so my three words are enthusiastic
supportive
and bald so these might be a little
obvious
but sometimes it's those obvious things
that really impact the way that you move
through
space so don't feel like everything has
to be
a deep kind of revelation about yourself
if it is great but sometimes it's those
immediate
elements of who you are that can often
lead to some of the most interesting
insights about who you are
um i garden for fun i find it really
relaxing and i love nature
um a skill that i've worked on which is
i guess kind of perfect for the work i
do is
reading applications and really trying
to understand who you
are um as applicants and really honor
the effort
and all of the detail that you're
investing into this process
i care a lot about diversity equity
inclusion and belonging both as you
think about it
in the u.s setting but also
internationally
how do we celebrate diversity within and
among diversity
how do we bring those perspectives
together so that we can learn from each
other
and how can we create spaces where
people feel comfortable
letting people know they're different
sometimes that can be the hardest thing
and if we're able to create these
inclusive spaces
when we feel comfortable and safe and
able to voice these
those are the moments that can lead to
some of the greatest growth
and support and relationship building
with those around you and so
that is really important to me and i can
talk about fish
this might seem a little facetious um
but
what i want you to do next is
continue adding things throughout and we
are actually going to start talking
about the holistic review process
more to come on that list so keep adding
to it but what
is it this is going to be the heart of
the conversation
um throughout this week and it's
important to understand our process
and the review process specifically so
that you can understand the utility and
purpose of each of the sections
once you're better able to understand
that and how we use them
that will hopefully help you understand
okay what types of information can i be
sharing
how should i share it and given the
whole range of things i could be talking
about
how i how can i distill them into you
know those word counts those
limits or as i think about it the
frameworks and canvases that are
provided for you to paint and kind of
color within
so definition of the holistic of
holistic as a philosophy and i'm gonna
go ahead and read this because
i think this is a really beautiful
encapsulation
of our philosophy for reading
applications as well and the evaluation
process here at the gsb
so holistic philosophy characterized by
comprehension of the parts of something
as
intimately interconnected and explicable
only by reference to the whole
so elements depend on each other for us
to understand the greater
picture of who you are and one thing
adds extra dimension
um and visibility into you know who you
are what you do
how do you show up in spaces definition
doing credit here to where it's coming
from oxford languages thank you
but what does this mean for you in our
evaluation process
what i want you to take a look at are
some of the key takeaways
as we're reading applications that
wholeness is really important
so we do not use formulas we don't use
equations
there's not an algorithm that we use to
make admissions decisions
at the gsp this might be very different
from admissions processes elsewhere
and especially international settings
where sometimes
that test is really a precursor or the
determinant of what happens or where
you go next that's not so at the gsp
so what we're looking at is so much
bigger than that
we're going to be unpacking that
throughout today
there are no benchmarks no cutoffs or
quotas as part of the evaluation process
so oftentimes i hear well how many
people do you take from
my industry or i hear you only take two
people from my country every year
and they come from x and y industries
one from each
and that is actually the furthest from
what our process
does we are taking a look at you as an
individual
where you know no one part of the
application
matters more than the other because each
adds to that
whole holistic view of who you are where
context really does
matter so maybe it is elements of your
industry that help determine
you know how might some of those
leadership
or accomplishments that you do in your
everyday work
how do those show up that looks
different in
a consulting setting than it might in an
entrepreneurial setting
but just because they show up
differently doesn't mean one is
necessarily more or less
important or valuable or impactful than
the other
it's just the context that changes that
can also be said for those of you who
might be applying
early right so maybe you're currently in
college or an early career professional
we understand that and that is built
into the application process
we don't expect you to have had neces
team leadership roles necessarily
we don't expect you to have anything
that's someone who've been working 10 11
12 years might have under their resume
or under their belt
you have different worlds we are looking
at you within yours
for those of you who might be on that
more experienced side of the spectrum
it's not just what you did but what did
you do
given that time how did you maximize the
resources
and opportunities that were provided for
you right
who are you because of that and what are
some of those footprints you left behind
right those footprints again are going
to look different depending on where you
are
what you did and even what you might
hope to do next
those are the key takeaways i want you
to take from here
we are really looking through our entire
application
to get the best sense of who you are who
you might show up in our classroom who
you might show up as in our classrooms
and in our community so what do we look
for
this is where we're gonna again come
back to you i think you are going to be
the best illustration
for the message that we're trying to get
across today so go ahead and bring back
that list
and to give a little preview of what i
wanted to do next
we are going to talk about three things
intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions
uh these are both a mouthful and can be
a lot to write down
so go feel free to use some acronyms
here
stanford and stanford as a whole is a
very
acronym friendly place so if i refer to
these as
iv dlp and pq or pq and c
um these are the things that i'm going
to be referring to please feel free to
use these um
the shorthand as part of this exercise
if you are writing on a word document
or some other space where you know you
might be a little bit more limited
in the ways you are using kind of text
boxes or whatever
go ahead and you are just going to put
iv
next to the thing that strikes you as
you know
encapsulating what intellectual vitality
looks like for you
so for me that i can talk about fish
teeth
i actually have a degree in marine
biology
there is something about nature and
ecosystems
and the way species interact with each
other that really speaks to me and just
fascinates me
um and i really love fish for multiple
reasons that we're not going to get into
today
except to say that both at a scientific
intellectual level as well as
elements of family and memories and
personal growth and history these are
all things that
you know uh makes sense to me and i
and so for you as i talk about the
descriptions for each one of those
categories
feel free to draw that line to make that
connection or you know add that
iv dlp like notation next to it in
whatever
format works best for you in the here
and now okay
so for those of you who are going to be
watching this later on
i'm going to give a description feel
free to pause after each
each description to give yourself time
to draw some of these lines and
connections
so let's get started again you can use
as many bullet points as many times as
you want no limits here
this is all about you okay so
i'm gonna clear my stuff uh we don't
need that clearing the
cluttering the space let's focus on our
criteria
so if you haven't done so already i
highly recommend that you go to
our evaluation criteria section of the
gsb
mba admissions website there's some
really great language here on all three
of these topics
for intellectual vitality there are some
rhetorical questions to help you
think about what are some of the
different ways this comes to life for me
in terms of demonstrated leadership
potential they're actually
examples of what are some of the types
of leadership competencies
that you might be exhibiting in your
life as well so definitely jump on that
website
bookmark it i have i find it incredibly
useful
um both for this process but also to
think about
hey how do i get things done what are
things that are important to me
how does this show up in my life so
intellectual vitality i like to think of
this as what is your relationship with
knowledge
it's so much more than a test score or a
gpa
right those are indicators of how you
performed on a test or how you did
enough in a classroom
but you were so much more than that what
are the things that make your eyes light
up
when you hear a topic what are the
things that you can talk about at length
and thinking about the type of place
business school is thinking about the
collaborative
environment at the gsb and how you're
learning as much
from your classmates professors speakers
as much as they are from you how do you
also
share that knowledge with others
everybody takes a different approach
and that's cool there is something about
different ways of learning and
understanding that when they come
together they can help push you
out of kind of where you might have been
before to really take a look at
issues and problems from new
perspectives and that's how we're going
to define and identify
the solutions of the future so how are
you going to bring that mindset
that learning growth element to the
table
where are the spaces that your mind
sings
demonstrated leadership potential dlp
think about this as two parts
demonstrated leadership
and leadership potential so both go hand
in hand
um but are slightly nuanced so
demonstrated leadership
are can be thought about as what are the
things you have done right
and context matters here for those of
you who might be applying
as a deferred candidate some of this
might be happening in college
for those of you who might be working
and in the professional world
some of that leadership might have been
on a project um
it might have been at an organization
team level
leadership can also be demonstrated on
an individual or one-on-one level
so think very broadly about this and
it's not just
what you've done but how have you done
it
okay what are some of those skill sets
that you've applied
what are some of those ah-ha moments or
how did you drive results
those are those out pieces that are just
as important to us in this process
as accomplishments part of the
application is to understand
you know from past behavior how is this
individual
um you know what are some of the ways
that they might behave again in the
future
this is a great indicator so unpacking
and disassembling the the process
behind the output is going to be a very
important tool for you
throughout this process and it's i think
something that is going to be incredibly
useful
as you're learning and going through
this kind of leadership development
journey
throughout business school and beyond
right what is that internal dialogue
that you can have here
so personal qualities and contributions
who are you what are the things from
your lived experience that are you're
going to be able to contribute
what are some of those perspectives that
you're going to be bringing to the gsb
both in the classroom and community
diversity broadly defined falls under
this
because different lived experiences will
come in with different
thoughts and ideas about things at the
gsb
one of our priorities how do we create
and cultivate
spaces where these you know differences
of opinions
are encouraged and supported so that
they come
up so that we can have these learnings i
know this is something that is important
as we continue to move into the future
where some of our problems
so many of our problems are going to
require folks coming acro
together from across so many different
ranges of
viewpoints backgrounds different
priority sets
how do we have constructive conversation
to figure out a
you know a possible path forward
what is your perspective how do you
bring it to the table
how are we using that as an opportunity
for the both of those around you
like who are you so
with each one of those go ahead and take
a moment
jump on your list we're gonna bring that
list back up build those connections
i did some of that right here um i used
three different colors just to make some
of the lines
easier so intellectual vitality
there's also this element of biology
that fascinates me
um what are some of the geographic
distributions
of native plants and how have those
evolved over time as
human geography has brought you know
crops
um and crops with them to different
parts of the world
and then how those pieces those um
ingredients been used in like
those recipes and what does that mean
for culture there i find all of that
stuff fascinating
um i love the application process i
think about it
a lot more than i probably should um
and it's something that at a leadership
level
i appreciate the opportunity help my
team
um learn grow and how can we facilitate
conversations
about things like bias about diversity
how
about lived experience and how does that
factor into the application and review
process so leadership
kind of both on that practical tactical
way and also in that thought leadership
within our department
and then personal qualities and
contributions a lot of different ways
this can go here
but in terms of caring about inclusion
and belonging
it's really important for me that my
teammates feel like they can show up
come as they are and are you know
how can we unlock our greatest potential
and effectiveness
by understanding and recognize and
really seeing each other
and that's kind of one of those things i
bring to the table for my team
so so if you are watching go ahead and
pause right now
draw some of these lines take a moment
because sometimes the lines
aren't always as clearly defined as you
think you might find some very
interesting pieces here so i talked a
little bit about that
inclusion element but you'll see like
not everything here is
super clearly defined like i don't know
where baldness comes into play for
intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential or
personal qualities right from the get-go
but i thought it was important enough to
include as one of my three words
so take some time to unpack that right
as i think about okay what does this
mean
oftentimes the way the world perceives
you
impacts the way that you are treated
over time you know that results in
me understanding like i do need to
moderate and uh modulate how i show up
depending on where i am maybe it's
clothes
maybe it's the words i use maybe it's
the body language
so how do i think about all of these
different dialects of code switching
in a way that helps make sure that this
and this
doesn't you know overly impact or bias
the way
folks treat me right that's something i
realize that i do on a subconscious
level
but and that comes from you know this
so even for things that might seem
facetious
even for things that might seem surface
level or
um really obvious i encourage you to
take a step back and understand and
really draw some of those connections
for yourself
again i'm talking a lot about this
internal dialogue about
how do you show up in a space sometimes
that's metaphorical
sometimes it's actual and through the
mba application process
and through the gsb application process
particularly
we invite you to go on that kind of
personal kind of development and
reflection journey
so already getting to some of that with
understanding your list
who you are and how do these elements of
our evaluation criteria
come to life for you these are going to
be different for everybody out there
you are the only person who really knows
that for you
that baldness comes across as
intellectual vitality and
not demonstrated leadership potential or
vice versa
maybe you are part of an organization um
for men
or women or those who identify other
as something other than man or woman um
to talk about baldness right so there's
different ways that you can
lead or have intellectual vitality or
demonstrate some of these personal
qualities
um that only you can define so
where do we find these things in our
application there are going to be eight
different sections
over the course of this week we are
going to unpack a lot of these
so tomorrow we have a panel with some of
my colleagues about testing transcripts
and academics there's a session on
letters of reference
one um coming up towards the end of the
week connecting the dots
i'm really excited by because that is
where we're gonna go really deeply in
how do these different parts of the
application work
in concert with each other how can you
think about them at the tactical
practical level
um in a way that will help you
understand okay
you know oh maybe this is a spot where i
can talk about this piece of myself or
i didn't realize that was important to
include here
today high level setting those
foundations each one of our
events this week will dive in with much
more detail
educational history um including your
transcripts what schools you have gone
to
kind of what are some of those learnings
and things you've done on that journey
to where you are today
test scores just one part of the broader
picture here
personal activities and awards kind of
who are you
kind of at that personal information
level
professional experience this includes
your resume
this works in concert with that
employment history section of the
application
and we'll talk a lot about that
relationship in our connecting the dot
session later this week
letters of reference has been a really
hot topic and our information sessions
has a question that comes up in the q
a so we really wanted to give it the
time and space
for us to go really go there and talk
about
how both you can set yourself up for
success as an applicant
and if you're watching as a recommender
or if you're working with a recommender
what are some things they can do as well
to help you shine in this process
the essays and optional short response
questions
these are opportunities to talk about in
your voice
what are the things that are important
to you and this is one of those places
where
as you start to unpack and really
understand you know
here's that list of 10 things about
myself or more
here's why it's meaningful for me here
are some of those connections
that's where you start to really step
out of you know
whatever boxes might be checked to
really add that fullness and dimension
and uniqueness to who you are and what
you bring to the table
and then there is an interview as part
of our application process each one of
our admitted students will go through an
interview
um these are behavioral based mostly
done by our alumni
and we'll talk a lot about interviews
how do you share your story
both starting it in the written form and
verbally
as in an interview and are sharing the
story seriously this week
so but getting beyond just sections how
do they work together
to help us understand you so coming back
to that definition of holistic just as a
reminder
we are looking at each one of these
sections to understand and get a
different window and angle to who you
are
right we're trying to build the fullest
picture as possible
notice that there's gaps in this image
uh there are pieces that you know we may
never know
fully to get that best picture how do we
close some of these gaps
how do we make sure that the details
that you're including in each one of
these little segments
provides the most vivid picture possible
so we understand that
oh yeah so this is your shoulder and not
you know
a blob or a chair but we're really
starting to see okay this
is the piece that fits in with the hole
so that we can go through your that
assessment kind of giving you that full
dude uh
like diligence and justice to who you
are
okay bringing back that list you thought
we were done with it
we're gonna do one more thing with it
before we go to q
a so thinking about those three things
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential
personal qualities and contributions we
are going to
draw lines through your list one more
time but we're going to take it a step
further
so tell me about a time when
so i talked a little bit about diversity
inclusion
so what this could look like is
this is where you get into that show
don't tell kind of
frame of mind i care about something or
for many of you who were talking about
passion how does that show up for you
right
how can we give these pieces some meat
on the bones
so that when we're going into the
application there's evidence
this is an evidence-driven process so
while there is no formula there is no
um there are no cut-offs there there is
no
pre-kind of preconceived notion of
who our admitted students are
and it's an evidence-based process so as
we're trying to build
that like compelling argument for why
you should be joining our class
it's those evidence pieces that are
going to be the most helpful
so drawing the lines between hey here
are some descriptors some high-level
things about who i am here is the
evidence for that
here's that quote-unquote proof and so
one of the ways that
i care about inclusion belonging and
that it showed up as
kind of something that i did in my life
it was an action that i've taken
to move something forward is that
in this past year as the as the united
states
really grappled with who we are as a
nation
also thinking about interracial kind of
dynamics and systems that allow some
folks to
some communities to thrive love forces
others to struggle like beyond what
could or should be happening the
university at stanford university hosted
a series of events
called brave spaces i was a facilitator
for these conversations
intentional spaces for us to talk about
race
difference justice what does that mean
how have we experienced it as
individuals and how can we bring this
conversation
kind of to the forefront of what we do
such that
the university can be a more inclusive
space where we can really
like work and operate to our fullest
potential and so
do that do this exercise come up with
that
these lists of things about who you are
and sometimes you know you might
have a stroke of inspiration somewhere
bring that in
if you're thinking hey is this important
for the application
let's take a look at the criteria that
stanford uses
how might this connect what's an example
for how this came out in the real world
and then that could be one way that you
start to identify
okay here are some things that i really
want to make sure come out
in my application here are some of those
landmarks that i want to provide
so that while i'm navigating this as an
applicant
whoever is reading this can also
navigate the course and journey of my
life in a way that they are seeing
the things that have really shaped who i
am and how i'm going to show up
so tips we are getting close i want to
make sure we get through these tips and
so that i can jump into that q a box
if you have questions go ahead and add
them here we also have an
upvoting feature so go ahead if there is
a question that you find
really resonates for you click that
thumbs up button
it's going to help elevate that question
to the top i'm going to do my best to
answer as many questions i can with you
know our final 10 minutes together
for some of them i might be referring
you to some other events throughout this
week
and others i'm really going to try and
unpack it some of this philosophical
and background understanding level to
help provide that understanding and
process
based approach as opposed to just the
output
one of my colleagues talked about this
and
talked about how are we coaching you to
self-coach through this process
how can we give you the tools knowledge
uh and toolkits
so that you can be your best
self-advocate through this journey
so let's get to those tips we're gonna
do a little bit more unpacking and then
get to the q
a so first own your journey
no two people came to the gsb following
the same trajectory
everybody does things a little bit
differently
know yours celebrate yours
you'd be surprised at how often the
things that you do
every day probably without even thinking
about it
are some of the most fascinating things
to us
um on the admissions side right the
things like
how do you operate within a team maybe
it's the way that you
interact with the people around you you
don't often think twice about it
it doesn't always come up with an
award or achievement or some thing
that like defines it but
that is a those are some ways to lead
right
so really take that step back um kind of
release whatever notions you might have
had about what
quote unquote leadership looks like
release whatever ideas
you have about what admissions wants to
hear
and take control of your story this is
me
this is what i want to tell the mba
admissions office
about myself as you take control of this
journey
like no one can tell you how or what you
should be saying
right people can give input folks can
provide some coaching
but ultimately you are the expert in you
so let that come to the forefront and
really anchor on the things that
matter to you one of the things that i
often see
um which is often a missed opportunity i
would say
is it can be really tempting to look at
different
models here's the thing that got me in
or this is what
you're supposed to do xyz to get into
stanford
because each one of you is different
because each one of you brings a
different
lived experience and skill set set of
competencies
for leadership action whatever lenses
you bring
that might have worked for someone and
if you try to mold yourself to that
sometimes the things that make you the
most effective
or the elements about you that can
really be the most impactful in a
business school application or journey
you might lose those because you're
trying to be someone else zelda we're
celebrating you
your classmates are going to be learning
from you so
own this journey find value in the
process and not just the outcome
and we're going to go a little bit meta
here i mean this both in terms of the
outcome of the application process
um yes admission would be great
and but the reality is that is not going
to be the outcome for everyone that said
this process going through the exercise
of understanding what matters to you
these are things that can help guide you
as
you come to different decision points in
your life
maybe you have two jobs that you might
be considering how do you choose which
one maybe
maybe it's by going with what matters to
you maybe there's an ethical dilemma
that you're facing
let's go back to these core mission
pieces and values that you hold
to help guide you through some of these
kind of points in life
so even beyond the application outcome
there is still
value behind going through it and really
taking the moment to process and allow
yourself
to go there think about this beyond just
the pure functionality of getting in
but rather maybe even think about it as
a coaching exercise that you are guiding
yourself through
as for the things in your application
you can also think about this as
not just the outcome but how did you do
it coming back to that dlp demonstrated
leadership potential
what did you do and how what was the
setting around it
who else was involved what happened next
tell me
more that is one of my favorite
questions kind of talking to folks that
tell me more
and so i really encourage you to take a
moment to reflect
oh remember reflect process
connect so remember the things that
happen things that you're
proud of reflect on the situation around
it
i mentioned some instances that could or
some elements that could be handy
but also reflect on how you were feeling
in those moments
what were you challenged by what were
you energized by
process you know take a moment
and think about how these things connect
to each other in all actuality i
probably should have ordered it as
remember reflect connect
process but i have to i admit and in
full disclosure here
remember reflect process connect is so
much easier to remember
that but we could say those process and
connect pieces go together
connect the dots right because of this
that happened
i was inspired by xyz see how these
elements connect to who you are today i
learned this
i applied it there and that process
piece
take time to process how all of these
different dots connect there might be
dots that you never realized existed
maybe it's through that exercise we did
today maybe you didn't know that you
really did engage with baldness
at an intellectual level give yourself
time to unpack
celebrate and like explore through this
and remember through all of it it all
begins
with you okay so that is what i have
prepared right now
so i'm gonna jump into our q a box
before we do that i really want to
encourage everybody here to continue
your journey at mystanford.mba
um with some short questions we're able
to create a dashboard that will help
consolidate some of the event that may
be of most interest to you
there is also an application tracker to
help keep you kind of up to date on
where you are and
yet you go into that finish line i
really encourage you
if you aren't sure whether or not you
should apply now or in the future
take a moment and think what is it that
you want to do
how can stanford get you there if you're
thinking
we can i encourage you go ahead do this
process
take these moments to really celebrate
your journey
um because tomorrow can be a very
beautiful thing and i want to make sure
that you give yourself every opportunity
to realize that
okay so let me go ahead we are gonna
jump into that q a box
so i'm gonna stop sharing for a moment
and here we go so here's a question from
anna
um a number of you have also um kind of
bumped this question up so anna imagines
that the gsb
like other business schools tries to
admit a diverse class
how does that affect how they try to
balance students from different cultures
countries industries etc so great
question here
i think ultimately the one number that
we're trying to target
is bringing in a class so for us that is
for 20-ish year to year
and even that it flexes um depending on
the circumstances right
but rather than focusing on that number
or is there some breakdown that we're
going towards
we're really looking at you as an
individual
one of the kind of amazing things and
things that i really appreciate
about the holistic review process is
that we think about
not just we don't think about you as
someone from x
place but how does being from x
place shape the perspective that you
bring
and i think if you ain't if you allow
yourself to
take a step and look at it from that
perspective you're gonna
have a lot more agency in demonstrating
to us
like that perspective that can bring
kind of that enhanced dialogue to the
classroom or
spark conversations in the community
this might sound like a little bit of a
tangent of an answer
uh but something that we talked about
something that dean moss has
talked to me about um and we've had
conversations about this is like
staying on your side of the net what
does that mean right
if you think about a game like tennis or
volleyball you are in control of what's
happening on your side of the net
what's happening and what your the other
person decides to do
that's up to them so as we think about
this application process
my goal with this week is to bring more
light
and visibility to what are the pieces on
your side of the net
so that you can understand okay here are
the steps i can take
left right around and so not that i'm
trying to give a non-answer
answer but at a practical sense
there's actually a whole field called
enrollment management
where this is part of the consideration
how are we bringing in
as diverse cohort as possible i think
one of the lucky things for us
is that we do get a really broad
representation of extremely talented
individuals from around the world
that said sometimes i do get the
question why are so many people from the
united states or
why are they so many people from
consulting is that going to
um be a disadvantage for me
part of this is that those tend to be
some of our largest pipelines
we can only admit the people who apply
and so that is that other part of
encouraging you to take a step and if
this is something that
you're thinking about don't count
yourself out because you
don't immediately identify with what it
looks like on our class profile
right so a couple different layers to
that answer
we really do care about the individual
and the talent that you bring
we will never admit someone just because
of one thing right and so regardless of
where you come from
like hopefully you're able to share all
of these pieces with us
to build that case for saying this is a
compelling individual
thank you for that question anna's from
the shot um
talking about very themes that are
within the bounds of including in the
application
can we touch upon what applicants should
avoid creating their
application uh this might be useful for
internationals who might not be very
familiar with the u.s admissions process
and expectations
i thank you deshaun for this question i
this is
at the heart of um what we are trying to
do
i would say there is very little that is
off-limits for the application so there
might be a topic that might feel
controversial
there might be a event in your life
that might not seem immediately business
related
but it really is important to how you
view yourself
when it comes to the gsb application and
i can't speak to
all applications out there but when it
comes to the gsb
application think about it as
what you're writing about is almost less
important than the so
what of it what are you trying to convey
about yourself
or who are you because of x y or z
things that you're trying to write about
okay and so
as long as that topic is in good taste
and
here's maybe one guideline that you
might take home with you is
if you step back and let's talk about
the app the essays for a second
if by the end of that essay i know more
about that topic
than i do about you or how you engage
with the topic
how that shapes your perspective what
you've done with it
if i know more about that topic than you
some element of you
that might be the moment to step back um
and
do a little bit of assessment and shift
kind of your angle on that
so ultimately very little is uh off off
off the rails here for this process
which is both empowering
and a little bit intimidating not
everything has to deal with business
again thinking about how the individual
kind of what you bring to the table is
so much more than kind of
the class that you might be taking of
you you are so much more than like a
test floor or transcript
like how can we recognize and celebrate
that so through this week as well so
that was a very high level answer
through this week we're actually going
to dig into
all of these elements very specifically
um and i'm really looking forward to our
panels because
i'm excited for the conversations to
come
okay all right question here and this is
more tactical practical
when does it matter like round one round
two no major difference here
um and we'll also be talking about some
of that tactical practical with the
connecting of the dots
um i have time for one more question
we're gonna stick to this
philosophical how do we understand the
process um
to set up and tee up the different
events we have this this week
and here's one from um
from cecilia is there an ideal balance
or ratio of these aspects so i'm
assuming
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential personal qualities
and contributions
would having too much or not enough in
one area be particularly detrimental to
an application
and i can say wholeheartedly the answer
is no
um you don't have to um have everything
right each one of you think about the
leaders and people
in your life that you look up to or find
really effective
everyone uses a different balance and
that's awesome as you're thinking about
your balance
right that's where we're starting to
unpack okay so in this list of things
what do you do how do you do them
okay here's the balance that i bring and
fully recognize and celebrate that other
areas like not every leader and
dean moss she is a her research
background is actually
in like leadership assessment so if
you're curious to learn more and want to
learn more
join us this friday for office hours
with dean moss and she talks about
those many different types of leadership
competencies
not every leader will express all of
them
and same in this application process not
everybody needs to express
everything some people are very spiky um
and really uh like excel in certain
areas and that's awesome
other folks are a little bit more
balanced and do varied things and that's
awesome as well
so regardless of your journey like there
is no
preset kind of balance that we're
looking for again there's
no formula no equation um to our process
we're really looking at you um kind of
in the fullness of you
so thank you again for joining us i want
to be respectful of everybody's time
this is just the beginning of our
conversation we set the groundwork
and started an exercise that you can do
to
start creating these stories and
understandings of who you are
so that over the course of the week we
can continue to process
unpack and answer questions um as many
as you have
in the meanwhile feel free to message
our uh
email inbox we have a team of folks who
are there to support
thank you so much for joining me on this
very first
event in application week navigating the
application
this crash course into the holistic
review process
i hope to see you across the events of
this week and answer as many questions
and really empower you to take that step
forward
remember it all begins with you thank
you again y'all